So today, a definitive declaration
from President
Zelenskiy
bluntly saying that he does
believe Ukraine will retake Crim
which, of course, was illegally
by Russia,
nearly a decade ago
under the Obama administration.
President Obama was in office,
I should say.
Both Russia and Ukraine
both claim ownership over Crimea
has become the symbolic battleground
in the war between Russia and Ukraine
Speaking to the World
Economic Forum, President Zelens
said Crimea is, quote, our land.
And he urged Western allies
to provide him
with more weaponry to regain
what is ours.
And now President Biden
may be willing
to do just that,
according to a new report
from The New York Times this mor
They say that despite the hard l
that they've taken in the past
from the United States
refusing to provide
Kiev with far reaching weapons.
Now that line is starting to sof
Of course,
the United States has always mai
that Crimea
does belong to Ukraine,
that it was illegally taken by R
But this comes
as the US
is also set to announce
one of the biggest military
aid packages to Ukraine
since the beginning of this war
nearly a year ago.
It is expected to be worth
two and a half billion dollars
and the first time
is going to include Stryker
combat vehicles.
CNN's Alex Marquardt is joining
Alex, good morning.
Tell us exactly what these
Stryker vehicles mean to Ukraine
and what it is
going to do
for the forces
there on the ground
who so clearly need the help.
Well, Caitlin,
what is notable in this
massive new package,
expected to be around $2 billion
say, is both
what is new in it
and what is not in it
that the Ukrainians
have been desperately asking for
The new elements are these Stryk
combat vehicles.
They are armored vehicles that w
Ukrainian troops to be carried
across the battlefield,
giving the Ukrainians
a significant
new mechanized capability,
particularly when combined
with the Bradley fighting vehicl
which were just committed
to Ukraine by the United Nited S
in the last aid package earlier
this month, which was
and is to this
to date the biggest military aid
Those two together will allow Uk
to really go on the offensive
to try to take back territory.
Now, the Stryker
is lighter and faster than the B
But the two together really do
give the Ukrainians
a significant new mechanized cap
And Alex,
this also comes
as there's
this remarkable
showdown happening
between the United States and Ge
It seems to be kind of percolati
where there is
this new German defense minister
over the decision
about sending tanks to Ukraine.
What's the latest on that?
Well, Caitlin, the U.S.
does want Ukraine
to get new Western tanks.
They are not sending their own t
American tanks,
because they're too
logistically challenging
the tank that most have settled
That would be best
for the Ukrainian fight
is the leopard, too,
which, as you say, is made by Ge
In fact,
the secretary of defense, Lloyd
Austin, is in Germany
as we speak in Berlin, meeting
with his German counterpart
to press the Germans
to send this tank to Ukraine.
Now, the Germans have said
they don't want to go this alone
They don't want to be
the only country out there doing
And other countries are saying
we're ready to go with you.
The Brits have committed a squad
of their tanks.
Other European countries saying
they're ready
to send their leopard tanks.
If Germany gives the word,
Germany has to give permission
because these are German tanks.
Senior defense officials
saying just yesterday
they are very optimistic
that they can get Germany to tha
by the end of the week.
All right.
We'll see what Secretary Ashton
Alex, thank you.
Joining me now is the former pre
of Ukraine, Petro Poroshenko.
Thank you so much, Mr.
President, for the time today.
So there you heard it.
The U.S.
had to deliver Stryker
combat vehicles
for the first time,
an additional Bradley fighting v
How significant
will this new equipment
be for the country
for First of all, I want
to thank the United States
people, United States government
and president for their great le
You play in supporting Ukraine
and in
protecting the free world
against the Russian aggression.
I can tell me that
this is the game changer because
armored vehicle from Canada,
200 armored vehicle from Great B
And 50 from Sweden, some from th
all together.
We expect that that should be ab
personal care.
And this is to really help us
to stop the Russian offensive op
and to provide the counter
defensive operation
already within two or three mont
This is
this I'm
just returned back from a small
we know exactly what is the situ
on the east of our country.
And this is extremely difficult
because the Putin concentrated
everything he can
for the for this attack.
And we are we and Putin plan.
And we applaud the transatlantic
leadership of the United States.
And we think that the everybody
now understand
that we are not only protecting
and you are not only supporting
and helping Ukraine, we together
protect freedom, democracy
of the whole free world.
There appears to have been
a change in strategy Mr.
President, in terms of how far t
is willing to aid Ukraine agains
prior to the last few days,
the US was said on the February
boundaries there
in terms of whatever
it would take to get
to the negotiating table.
Now, it seems that the United St
seems open
for Ukraine to actually take bac
or attempt
to take back Crimea by providing
with weaponry
to at least attack
that land bridge, connecting Rus
to Crimea.
Of course
Crimea was illegally annexed
by Russia in 2014.
Ukraine has always been defiant
that is your mission to take bac
you say it is yours.
I'm curious to get your response
to what appears to be a shift in
on the US's part to
first of all
Ukraine never have any doubts
that we should release
from Russian aggressor
every single piece of Ukrainian
and the only factor that we can
and provide the territorial inte
and sovereignty to your plane on
all the territory in clothing
that are owned by them
including the Crimea.
And with that situation we
I personally don't see any chang
in Ukrainian policy and I don't
practically changes
in the American policy
because me
as a president
all five years feels the strong
and reliable support of United S
including Crimea in question.
We need
the more support from the United
In the other question, because
I can confirm you
that it would be impossible.
The peace
without Ukrainian membership in
And with that situation,
we really also expect
the great leadership
of the United States because Ukr
already passed the
most difficult exams for
Floyd
being the candidate in major maj
Now, Ukraine,
as much as Ukraine need me to.
So really count on your support.
Mr.
President,
if I could just get you to weigh
as we conclude here
on what your thoughts are,
what your message would be to Ge
Chancellor Schultz,
given that there appears
to be a bit of a conundrum
with regards to the other
heavy weaponry that you need rig
and that is tanks,
the United States,
as they are not going to be send
Abrams tanks,
but they are in favor of Germany
sending their leopard tanks ther
About 2000
leopard tanks
that have been distributed
to other Naito allies.
Germany
at this point has said
they will not do so
and not even permit other countr
to deliver
tanks to Ukraine
unless the United States
delivers its own tanks.
What do you think Germany is up
and what is your message
to Chancellor Schultz
when he says that
he won't bring you tanks now?
Look, all Western world,
the mainstream should learn unit
You should learn how to speak
one voice policy,
Germany,
United States and other member s
a damned of the day.
We can bring to this situation
that Poland
and other NATO member states
will supply for us
the tank
without the permission of German
It can be challenged from the
United Kingdom,
apart from Germany and others
We definitely now need the tank.
Without tank,
it is impossible
to provide the offensive operati
And if we expect him that we sho
through Russian aggressor away
from Ukrainian territory.
This is impossible without defen
This is very difficult
with our jet fighter
and this is impossible without t
All right.
The sooner we do that, the bette
And this is my message to
Chancellor Schultz. I know
the chancellor
from the position of the Germany
Now, it's
strongly connected
with the position of nature
and in other messages
that the whole European people
support supply of Ukraine, the t
All right.
Well,
the president may be paying
significantly higher price than
Well, President Petro Poroshenko
we appreciate your time.
We'll have to leave it there for
Thank you so much for joining us
Stay safe. Stay safe.